- [Kelly] I mean, I love her.
Like I loved her before we did Hollywide.
Hollywide, what?
- Hollywide!
- We didn't do Hollywide Game Night;
it was Hollywood Game Night,
and it was super fun.
I loved her before then, but I will say,
before we get to my love
of Peppermint and Alias
and all things you do,
you've met Meryl.
How is she?
(audience laughs)
Is she great?
- I mean, I met her brief.
I don't know her.
I'm not, you know...
- But you met her,
and you're like famous,
and you're in movies,
and she's famous and in movies,
and so you're kinda the same.
- Yeah, we're kinda the same, yeah.
No, I did a play with Kevin Kline.
We did Cyrano.
- Love him!
- [Jennifer] Yes.
- Sophie's Choice.
- Yes. And they were old pals.
And every night,
he didn't want to know
who was in the audience.
And every night he would say,
(deep voice)` "I think
I heard Meryl laugh.
Did you hear Meryl?
Meryl's out there."
And then the night that she came back,
we were like, "She's here!
You're finally here!"
- Oh my gosh!
- But she's, you know, she's a person.
- [Kelly] Yeah
(audience laughs)
No, totally.
Totally a normal human,
that's why I think I love her so much,
'cause she doesn't-
- She seems like she has mom friends.
- Exactly, like normal mom friends.
Yeah, I'm obsessed with her.
I'm obsessed with you, too, though, so-
- You know what, you know
what I love about you?
- What?
- You have no chill.
(audience applause and laughter)
- No I don't.
(laughing)
I literally run, like
(trills) all the time.
- You make me seem calm.
- I know!
- I feel a very zen vibe
because I have to yin to your yang
and I feel like it really works.
- [Kelly] I know.